man I mean I was running a weeder
product you know a lot of guys were
blown up which which is not uncommon I
just doing coke yeah the only reason the
only reason I didn't my dad was a doctor
and he just said don't do it from day
one man he said you're gonna
this this guy can see this happening in
your business I don't know anything
about it but you know it happens not not
just to you guys but because it was wear
and tear and travel oh yeah it's almost
a necessity yeah but I avoided that but
oh man I'll tell you I've I've had 17
nervous breakdowns
no [__] I was just so exhausted
and one night I I wrestled for an hour
in Orlando or the old Eddie Graham
Sports Arena which is a tin building 104
degrees and I wrestled Butchery
when my heart was like racing like hell
so I called my dad on a pay phone
and he was in Minneapolis I said dad my
heart's racing
he said what was the last time you went
to bed
and I said I don't know I thought to
myself I didn't want to answer so I said
well I went to bed last night at what
time
so that I never went to bed right and
then
so I had to go I had to go to
um Tokyo the next day
and I got in a plane going God I can't
do this
so I drank all the way to Narita drank
14 hours
my baby slept two hours but I woke up
kept drinking right
this isn't like 83 or 84.
Landon Narita back then we had the paper
ticket and I said I just can't do this
and I could hear Bob's wife flare son
you know
I walked over to the guy I said when's
the next flight back in the United
States
he said we got one for Seattle leaving
in 20 minutes
I said that when back they didn't have
that deal but the bags took the paper
ticket we'll be back I flew up from
Narita to Seattle Seattle to Chicago
Chicago to Charlotte
and to make a long story short
I sat down next to this guy
I sat down where sat down next to this
guy on the plane
going back and Rita to Seattle
and they go do you mind if I talk to you
he said no why
he said I said I'm having a nervous
breakdown I need someone to talk to him
and he and he said really I said yep I'm
having a nursery account
and um so we talked all the way to say
I'll drink all the way to Seattle
and then I slept to Chicago
and I walked and got another plane I
landed in Charlotte
and the firm order was there Jimmy
Crockett he said you got to go back
you're advertised
we got back on the plane never even left
the airport went all the way back to
Tokyo oh my God drinking again
I mean that I was having a full-fledged
nose breakdown he got there and went to
the arena wrestled an hour
and I broke the sweat and holding it
just started over again but the guy from
Seattle we changed addresses right
he sent me a Christmas card for 10 years
he said I didn't know how famous it were
really enjoyed talking to you man you're
an interesting guy
isn't that crazy I didn't know how
famous you were when I made really
enjoyed talking I hope you're feeling
better
oh full Sledge breakdown man God what
did it feel like when you're having a
nervous breakdown like what like what do
you kind of go through I had one a few
years ago oh you just you lose control
of me you just like you're looking for
someone to talk to it's straight it's
hard to walk up to someone and say hey I
think I'm having another breakdown most
people want to run a window don't forget
to call the cops
he's a wacko
yeah call God no I waited until the
plane took off before it sent it to him
I don't want him calling him
you're like hey remind me when we take
off I got something to do yeah and
nowadays can you imagine walking on the
plate in it will you talk to me I'm
gonna break down the whole game yeah
they'll call you racist can we land the
plane please and they put you in the
suit and take you off the floor
oh I got about five of them no kidding
yeah it's heavy huh you know
agoraphobias where you have to be close
to something oh yeah yeah no drama
agoraphobia yeah you can't be alone you
can't walk outside of your house oh you
have that you think annoy at it wow yeah
I had it for about six months
I couldn't I couldn't get myself to
leave and drive to the airport
I mean I mean it's horrible what do you
think brought it on when you feel back
in it like would it because I was just
living a crazy lifestyle
do you think you felt bad about anything
or do you think you just it was just so
much like drinking and partying oh just
so much drinking a party and I just I
didn't sleep yeah and the one thing I
did do which is kind of legendary in our
business
is regardless of what I did to myself
I worked out every day and sometimes I
just pushed myself too hard and that
would cause that and then
you know having different promoters try
to
you know like when I cut my hair I
really lost my mind when I cut my hair
Jim heard
Spartacus put a hearing on I'm Ric Flair
[__]
you know there's something you know when
I cut my hair and I walked through the
Charlotte Airport nobody knew who I was
I wanted to absolutely walk in the
bathroom and kill myself
he used to be normally walked around her
area combing my hair and all that now I
got the surfer Joe Eric I just give me a
break
uh you know I mean Native Americans it
was a big thing to them to have their
hair and hook each other's hair yeah
captured one another they would scalp
one I started a trend with it yeah and
then they have some promoter I mean I
still can't believe I gave into them
yeah
man it's funny because I've cut my hair
before and it [__] hurt me oh I can
remember the girl named Mary Riley she
said are you sure you want to do this
I said no I don't want to do it but I
almost have to keep my job hmm but man I
was I was in shock that that alone
wasn't what was a nervous breakdown
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one